and then i said octopus aliens didn't
need to become
christian because they're not affected
by original sin you should have been
there
pastor jeffery started crying well no
i'm sorry i missed it
it's your fault for having a hangover or
it's god's fault for putting sunday
morning after saturday night
meanwhile could you take me to radio
shack sure maybe later
later's a little vague could you please
be more specific
when i'm getting ready how's that better
but i'd really like to nail this down
no why don't you ask your father to take
you
dab what can you please take me to radio
shack
i'm busy ask your meemaw i did she said
to ask you
well ask her again seems
counterintuitive but all right
me mom oh lord
everybody okay no
stephanie hansen's daughter was in a car
accident last night she
died oh no
my god she was merely 16.
that's horrible is there anything we can
do
i don't know um oh i need to call folks
at the church
any more thoughts on radio shack
sheldon do you really think this is the
appropriate time to ask that question
i did but now i'm second guessing myself
[Music]
how come we don't get to go to the
funeral why would you want to go to a
funeral
i've never been to one you get to be my
age you get to go to plenty that's like
a hundred years from now
you make it hard to love you do you
really see a dead body
sometimes how close do you get to it
real close if you want
and the clothes they're wearing is that
the clothes they become a ghost in
depends in the movie goes patrick swayze
has on the outfit that he dies in
casper runs around butt naked maybe he
died naked
that's fun to think about and y'all
wonder why you're not at the funeral
[Music]
hold on hold on thank you god for this
food we're about to receive and for the
nourishment of our bodies and bless the
hands prepared it
amen we're doing this at breakfast now
yes i think it's a nice idea you know
she's eating count chocolate
doesn't he play for the other side i'm
so glad god blessed you with a sense of
humor george
mom have you received any distressing
phone calls today
no why just wondering if it's an
appropriate time to ask if you could
take me to radio shack
sorry sweetheart i can't today i have to
bring this food over to the hansen
family
then i have my new prayer group and
after that i'm going to get started on a
faith garden in the backyard
the faith garden what the hell is that
language
it's an outdoorsy place for me to speak
to god
don't try to speak to him indoorsy yes
but in the backyard
i can enjoy the beautiful world he gave
us you can also smell the sparks chicken
coop
well i think it sounds nice thank you
i'm gonna need your truck to get all the
dirt and flowers and tools that i need
sure oh oh almost forgot can you keep an
eye out for a rock big enough to paint a
sawmill
i could do that wish me luck look
is mom okay how the heck should i know
she left
you can say hell
[Music]
so